we have is
from from china
um she's uh one of the strongest female
players in the world
from
from team chronic
and she's gone d4 and uh i will just uh
see if i can get the the same sort of um
model game there
obviously i cannot since since she went
for knight f3 there declining the
the banker gambit which is obviously a
bit sad
which line should i go for here
let's go e6
okay she goes for g3
um
yeah i don't know what line to play here
so i'll just play something
bishop e4
bishop b2 i'll go bishop c5
and push b7
i used to play
play this line
back in the old days
i had it against our unknown for
instance
the problem is
i don't think the line is very good
like in general white is a little bit
better
but
it's not that much
i'm trying to get some sort of solid
hedgehog type of position and after rook
c1 i think i can set it up
my knight only problem is my knight is
on c6
should ideally
um
be on d7 since it's a little bit more
flexible there
but i think we'll get around to it
eventually
a6
now this is the hedgehog
structure with these four
characterized by these four spines
so anytime you try to
go past them
you will be stung
by the hedgehog
okay she goes for exchanges which is
very uh
very sensible but now i think i have a
relatively
easy game um
she's still probably slightly better but
my my next moves are fairly easy
um
don't know yet if
um knight f6 bishop d6
that works okay we'll go h6 then
not worried about sax
once she goes
uh bishop d3 i will go knight f6
now we'll
aim for either b5 or d5
if b5 there's knight a5
then i can go queen a8 seems reasonable
playing very fast though which is uh
very sensible
yeah c6 was probably a good move i sort
of underestimated that yeah and then
started c5 and then c6
i missed missed c6 while i was busy
yapping
now i'll probably have to sack a pawn
here since i would be very passive
otherwise i need the d5 square for the
night
yeah this could be a difficult game
it already is a difficult game but it
could be even more difficult
but at least i got her thinking a little
bit on this one
so bishop t4 i'm just sure about now
we've got knight t5
oh she still got knights a
a5 and the knight b7
okay we'll go rook c7 then rook c8
try to pick up the pawn that way
our bishop c5 yeah that's a good move
oh and bishop d6 as well
i'm missing everything now
okay this is massive trouble
we'll have to hustle
we'll seriously have to hustle this one
but i have hopes
now there could be problems on the
diagonal for her
queen of three there's knight e3
king h3 yeah that's sensible bring the
bishop around
okay
let's no i missed knight of three i was
thinking rook c1 okay i still have it
though
i was i was i actually saw it in the
other line but i missed it here but i
think this is still winning
uh gf queen queen g2 and there will be
mates otherwise h5 is threatening mate
um
but yeah that was a little bit fortunate
but
that's
what i learned earlier about beating
beating very strong players that
they generally
don't give up if there are tricks they
will find them and i think
for all of my poor play in this game
my resourcefulness
was very was very strong but i have to
say she played well she played very fast
and outplayed me up to a certain point
c5
c6 was very strong
and
i only hustled a bit better at the end